For breakfast today,
I couldn't decide whether I wanted something sweet or savory,
but I did know that I want bread and butter,
so I made two variations of each.
I started by scoring my blueberry lemon sourdough loaf
that has been proofing in the fridge for a couple days,
placing it in my Dutch oven before adding some ice,
popping the lid on,
and baking it for 45 minutes.
While that was baking,
I decided to get started on my butter.
Whipped some heavy cream until my solid butter
separated from my liquid buttermilk,
and then I squeezed as much buttermilk out
before running it under cold water and setting it aside
for the savory version.
I wanted to make a ramp and chive butter,
so I blanched my ramps and then chopped them up really finely,
did the same with my chives, and then realized that my bread was ready.
So I pulled my blueberry loaf out and scored my plain sourdough
before popping that one in the oven.
For about 50 minutes that was baking,
I combined my ramps,
chives, and some flaky sea salt with my butter
before rolling it up in some wax paper.
I placed that in the fridge
and moved on to making a sweet butter to go with my blueberry loaf.
I decided on a browned maple vanilla salted butter,
which is one of my favorite butters. Now,
melted it down and then whisked it,
and once it was ready,
I placed On a plate
I had some beautiful heirloom tomatoes that I was craving.
So I added them to a plate with some olive oil, salt,
pepper and some French radishes that I had,
and pulled out my sourdough loaf and let it cool,
and then breakfast was done.
There's nothing better to me than a fresh loaf of bread
with some butter on it.
And this hit the spot.